ORDER AND WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON PLEASE NOTE
THE FOLLOWING TODAY WE HAVE NINE
MEASURES ON THE AGENDA. THREE ON
CONSENT FILE ITEM THREE SB.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY AS AMENDED BY
SENATOR B<c.cyan>.</c>
FILE ITEM SB THREE SIXTY SIX BY
SENATOR CHIANG AND FILE ITEM
SEVEN SB. THREE EIGHTY THREE BY
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME BACK DR
RUMBULA TO OUR COMMITTEE.
LASTLY PLEASE NOTE ARE GENERAL
GUIDELINES FOR BILLS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE STILL OUT
TESTIMONY FOR TWO WITNESSES
SUPPORT. TWO WITNESSES FOR
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK EACH FOR TWO
MINUTES.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT NOR
IN OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES WHEN I CALL FOR
TWEETERS.
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER CATEGORY.
ONLY TWO WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH.
FILE ITEM.
ONE SB FOURTEEN SENATOR GLAZERS.
WELCOME AND YOU MAY BEGIN.
WHEN YOU ARE READY?
BEGIN WITH FILE I IT -- FILE
ITEM ONE SB.
FORTY I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS BILL
THE THAT WOULD AUTHORIZE AN
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR BOND ON THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT.
FACILITIES AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN A DECADE
SINCE CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO DEDICATE FUNDS TO
BUILD AND REPAIR HIGHER
EDUCATION CLASSROOMS RESEARCH
LABS.
AND LIBRARIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND NO HIGHER EDUCATION SPECIFIC
BOND HAS PASSED SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO ALL THE BOND
DOLLARS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE LAST
RECEIVED IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
HAVE DRIED UP.
PROJECTS ARE BEING SIDELINED AS
THE CSU AND YOU SEE ARE
SCRAMBLING TO MAINTAIN OLD
BUILDINGS.
AND FACILITIES. TO ADDRESS TO
ADDRESS SHORTAGES AND KEEP PACE
WITH TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES BOTH
SYSTEMS WILL SOON NEED MORE
CLASSROOMS LABS AND OTHER
FACILITIES TO MEET.
STUDENT NEEDS.
THE BOND MONEY IN THE BILL COULD
ALSO BE USED FOR CONSTRUCTION
RECONSTRUCTION EARTHQUAKE.
RETROFITTING AND REMODELING OF
EXISTING OR NEW FACILITIES.
ACCORDING TO BOTH SYSTEMS I KNOW
WE'LL HEAR FROM THEM IN JUST A
MOMENT THEY HAVE COMBINED
CAPITAL NEEDS OF SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. FOR SHORT AND LONG TERM
PROJECTS.
WE ALL KNOW HOW VITAL OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ARE TO
OUR ECONOMY AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT STUDENTS NEED TO BE
EQUIPPED WITH THE CLASSROOMS
LIBRARIES SLAPS THAT WILL
PREPARE THEM.
FOR FUTURE CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE.
THIS BILL WILL GIVE VOTERS THE
CHANCE TO CONTINUE THE PROUD
LEGACY OF MAINTAINING AND
IMPROVING OUR UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITNESSES HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE UC AND CSU SYSTEM AND
WOULD LOVE.
TO OFFER UP THEIR TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MERRY MORE OIL
WITH THE CSU WE'RE PLEASED TO BE
CO CO SPONSORING THIS BILL WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR CLAY GLAZER.
FOR OFFERING HAT THE BILL AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS MORE THAN
HALF OF CS USE FACILITY SPACE IS
OVER FORTY YEARS YEARS OLD AND
THE THIRD IS OVER FIFTY YEARS
OLD.
THE FOUR BILLION DOLLARS SHARE
THE BOND FRUIT FOR CS YOU WOULD
HELP US TO ADDRESS DEFICIENCIES
AND OUR OLDER BUILT BUILDINGS
AND PROVIDE SAFE AND RELIABLE
FACILITIES WHERE OUR STUDENTS.
FACULTY AND STAFF CAN LEARN
TEACH AND AND WORK IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW US TO GROW.
OUR CAMPUSES SO THAT WE WE
CONSERVATIVE CHANNEL STUDENTS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
EXPERT WITNESS PAUL POGBA NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO IN FRONT OF
YOU OF THAT POCONO CHIEF OF
FACILITIES PLANNING WITH THE CSU
AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS THAT COME UP
DURING THE OF COURSE THE MEETING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA ALSO
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
UNIVERSITY NIFORNIA
IS NOTED IN ALICE'S EXTENSIVE
NEEDS -- WE DO -- FEEL THE NEED
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL FUNDS IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO SERVE.
GROWTH AND STUDENTS AS WELL AS
PROVIDE FOR SEISMIC ANOTHER
SORTS OF RENEWAL AND UPGRADE
THAT ARE NOT SERVED IN THE
UNIVERSITY.
AND IF THE AUTHOR OR I'M SORRY
THE CHARITABLE CONNECTED SURE
THE BOUNCE MY TIME WITH MY
COUNTERPART FROM THE OFF THE
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DOUG
STIMSON AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CAPITAL ASSETS
STRATEGY IT'S AT THE OFFICE THE
PRESIDENT. FOR THE UNIVERSE TO
CALIFORNIA -- MY GROUP OVERSEES
THE CAPITAL PROGRAM FOR THE
UNIVERSITY.
IN MY REMARKS TODAY ARE REALLY
BRIEF -- CANNOT BUT I'M
AVAILABLE AT YOUR CONVENIENCE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US ALL TO SPEAK.
THE UNIVERSITY HAS A VERY LARGE
CAPITAL NEED INCLUDING FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH PAST AND
FUTURE. FOR SEISMIC IN LIFE
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS FOR
RETROFITS AND REPLACEMENTS AND
ALSO FOR SUPPORTING AND WHAT WE
CALL AN AGING PHYSICAL PLANT --
MANY OF OUR BUILDINGS ARE ARE --
OVER THIRTY YEARS OLD OVER OVER
HALF OF THEM.
SO THE PROPOSED HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES BOND ACT WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT YOU SEE STUDENTS.
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF AND BY
EXTENSION THE ENTIRE STATE.
ON WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE ACT AGAIN I'D BE DELIGHTED
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA PAUSE JUST TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO MADAM
SECRETARY?
MEDINA PRESIDENT CHOI HERE
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM.
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE
[inaudible]
LOW.
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU QUORUM IS
ESTABLISH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ERICA ROMERO BEHALF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
MERRY WASHINGTON WITH KOUSEI
SOONER SO STATION IN SUPPORT.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALLIANCE OF
VENTURA.
AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES HOME
TO CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS AND UC
SANTA BARBARA IN SUPPORT.
NEIL SWEENEY UNREAD BEHALF OF
UAW LOCALS -- TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY TEN AND FOUR ONE TWO THREE
REPRESENTING ABOUT -- FORTY
THOUSAND TEASE READERS AND
TUTORS AND RESEARCHERS AT C. S.
U. N. YOU SEE WE TEACH IN THE
CLASSROOM TO WORK IN THE LABS
SUPPORT THIS BILL VERY STRONGLY
THANKS.
ADAM HOW TO BE UC DAVIS STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SUSTAIN NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH CARE
AND FIGURED ISSUE A STANDARD I
WAS -- BUT NOT FOR THE SPONSORS
AND OR YOURSELVES THE THE
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO THE
THE SPLIT EVENLY OF THE
RESOURCES.
AND YET THAT OF THE CAMPUSES IN
THE NIGHT OF STUDENTS THAT THIS
ISSUES POTENTIALLY HAD WAS THERE
ANY CONVERSATION I THOUGHT
BEHIND THAT.
OF THE EVEN DISTRIBUTION OFTHAT
OF THE FIFTY FIFTY SPECIFICALLY.
THROUGH THEIR PLEASE AND THANK
YOU CENTER THANK YOU SALLY
MEMBER LOVE FOR THE QUESTION.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A COMMON
QUESTION ASKED THAT WHEN THESE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE PUT FORWARD
AND I THINK THAT.
MY FEELING HAS BEEN THAT THEY
BOTH HAVE SIGNIFICANT NEEDS THAT
WON'T EVEN BE MATCHED BY IT BY
THIS MEASURE -- AND THAT -- I IN
THE SPIRIT OF THE GREAT
COALITION THE THAT'S BEEN PUT
TOGETHER BEHIND THIS I THINK THE
EVE EVEN SPLIT IS I THINK
SOMETHING THAT BOTH SYSTEMS ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND I CERTAINLY AM AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S PRESENTED THE WAY IT IS
TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
AS A FORMER RON.
UNIVERSITY FACULTY MEMBER HI --
HIGHLY -- AM INTERESTED IN --
SUPPORTING ANY MEASURE SO BUT
THE I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
REGARDING -- THIS MEASURE EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS TO IT YOU'LL
BOND THIS IS.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF OUR ADDITIONAL
TAX BURDEN.
WE NEED TO CREATE THE A RELATED
TO THAT I WONDER.
OF FIRST OF FOR THROUGH THE OUR
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHMENT.
OF THE BUILDING WHEN THEY ARE
BUILT -- TO WHAT THEY JUST A
BILL THAN THE NORM MAINTENANCE
COSTS SO.
MANAGERS ABILITY IN IN THE CHEN
ARE BUDGET THAT THE UC'S WAS CSU
RECEIVER.
WITH THE UNIT TO A SET ASIDE --
BUILDING -- MAINTENANCE COSTA
SEPARATELY SL ONE QUESTION.
NUMBER TWO IS -- HOW LONG?
WITH THE SEC EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS AT THAT TO RECREATE THAT
THAT WILL.
MAINTAIN IS A CARIBBEAN NEXT A
FIFTY YEARS OR IN PERPETUITY OR
JUST A TEN YEARS [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
AND AND THE QUESTION IS THAT --
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME.
EXTRA ORDINARY MONO OF SURPLUS
RIGHT NOW I CAN'T EXACTLY
REMEMBER TO MY MEMORY ELECT THE
TWENTY ONE P. AND DAUGHTERS --
WHY CAN WE SEE YOU -- SELL US
SOME OF THAT THE MONEY ONE TIME
MONEY THAT WITHOUT COSTING ANY
ADDITIONAL TAX BURDEN OF BURDEN
ON THE CITIZENS -- THOSE ARE THE
DUTCH GENERAL QUESTIONS SO I
COME TO REALIZE SO -- BEFORE A
WEEK COSTA DISCOUNT ABOUT TEN
ARCHITECT.
OKAY WELL LET ME TRY TO GIVE IT
A SHOT AND MY COLLEAGUES HERE
MAY.
WANT TO ENHANCE MY ANSWERS.
I THINK PART OF THE REASON WE
HAD THE VINES IS IT SIGNIFICANT
TODAY IS BECAUSE THAT WE FALL
OUT IT TO DETERIORATE WITHOUT
REALLY RESPONSE OVER MANY MANY
DECADES.
AND SO THEY'RE THERE FOR THE
THINGS GET OLDER AND WE HAVE TO
FIND SOME WAY TO CATCH UP AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK THE THE BONDS
PROPOSED AS IT IS SET BEFORE YOU --
THERE THERE IS MAKING HIS MONEY
THAT IS PROVIDED TO MAINTAIN
THESE FACILITIES OVER THE YEARS
BUT THAT'S BEEN SUBJECT TO THE
BUDGET PROCESS THAT WE ALL
PARTICIPATE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE BUDGET THAT
WE WILL BE POTENTIALLY VOTING ON
THIS WEEK.
DOES PROVIDE AFFABLE SYSTEMS
SIGNIFICANT MAINTENANCE MONEY TO
TRY TO KEEP THOSE FACILITIES
RUNNING.
AND USABLE.
AND THAT OF COURSE IS SUBJECT
EVERY YEAR TO THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THIS ATTEMPT TO DEAL WITH MORE
THE THE CAPITAL NEEDS THAT ARE
OUT THERE -- HAS THE LABS AND
CLASSROOMS OF DETERIORATED SAID
THEY'RE NOT USABLE -- AND IN
MANY WAYS.
THIS IS ABOUT PAYING IT FORWARD
JUST LIKE OUR PARENTS PAID IT
FORWARD FOR THE FACILITIES THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF OVER.
MANY YEARS -- IN THE PAST.
AND SO IT HAS A LIFE A LIFE
FLOOD OF FOR THESE NEW
FACILITIES OR THE THE
RECONSTRUCTION IS THE XISTING
FACILITIES OF ANOTHER OF DECADES
INTO THE FUTURE.
SO THE THE BONDS WILL BE PAID
OFF -- OVER THIRTY FORTY YEARS
THE FACILITIES THAT WILL BE
PROVIDED IN THIS MEASURE WILL BE
THERE FOR THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS.
AND SO IT IS TRYING TO CATCH UP
WITH.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVEN'T
MAINTAIN THOSE FACILITIES AS AS
WE WOULD LIKE.
TO AND THE CHANGING REQUIREMENTS
OF OUR OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
EDUCATION WORLD TODAY.
THAT WE CAN PAY IT FORWARD --
FOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF
STUDENTS SO THAT BE MY MULTI
PRONGED ANSWER TIER THREE
QUESTIONS.
HAVE YOU ATTEMPTED -- TO OF
GOVERNANCE BUDGET BUT THAT THEY
CAN USE THAT THE AN EXTRA MONEY
THE US.
WELL HE HAS IS PROVIDING SOME
MAINTENANCE MONEY I IN THE
BUDGET.
BUT YOU KNOW PRIOR TO THIS BOND
THAT THE OBLIGATION AT LEAST AT
THE LAST GOVERNOR.
SERVE FOR EIGHT YEARS WAS TO PUT
THAT -- REQUIREMENT ON TO THE
SYSTEMS THEMSELVES.
AND BY DOING SO IT MEANT THAT
THE THAT THE OBLIGATION FOR THAT
CAPITAL.
HAD AT AT HAD A AS A POSSIBILITY
THAT WOULD WOULD BE -- FUNDED BY
TWO WHICH SHOULD.
TUITION INCREASES THAT NONE OF
US HERE LIKE -- BUT THAT THAT
WAS THE A REVENUE SOURCE FOR ANY
CAPITAL OVER THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS -- AT THE SYSTEMS WITH
EITHER EXISTING REVENUE OR OR
OTHER MONEY THAT -- COULD COME
IN THE FORM OF TUITION.
AND I THINK THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE THINK -- IS THE PRUDENT
COURSE THE THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM WERE BUILT BY THE ALL THE
TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA WE ALL
SUPPORTED THOSE.
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IT
WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WE SET UP
THE STUDENTS THAT GO ON THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE THAT OBLIGATION SO
WE HAVE ALL PAID COLLECTIVELY.
AND THAT'S WHAT BONDS DO IS THEY
COLLECTIVELY ALL SHARE IN THOSE
COSTS OVER TIME OVER MANY MANY
DECADES NOT JUST FUNDED IN ONE
SIMPLE.
A BUDGET -- THAT HAS AT SOME
SURPLUS MONEY AVAILABLE FOR THAT
CAP OF ONE TIME COSTS THESE ARE
SIGNIFICANT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU A LONG TERM FUNDING
MECHANISM -- THAT HAS GRADUAL
STATE FIND COSTS RATHER THAN A
ONE TIME WHICH COME AND GO.
IF I DON'T QUESTION THAT THIS
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS SO A GEO
BONTA HOW LONG LAW OR THIS
MAINTAINED -- A TOTAL OF A TOP
SHAPE OF THE BUILDING THAT
CURRENTLY YOU AYE ENVISIONING TO
MAINTAIN.
I DON'T WANT TO MISLEAD YOU TO
SAY THAT THE SAN HOUSE GOING TO
SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS FOR BOTH
SYSTEMS -- IT DOESN'T THAT NEEDS
ARE EVEN GREATER AND THESE ARE
THESE ARE CHOICES THAT THEY WILL
MAKE IN TERMS OF HOW THEY SPEND
THAT MONEY THEY'LL GO THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS.
A PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS WITH
HIM PUT FROM ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
I THOUGHT THAT ALLOW THE REGIONS
IN THE TRUSTEES TO MAKE
THOUGHTFUL CHOICES ABOUT WHERE
THOSE EXPENDITURES WILL OCCUR
EACH YEAR.
IN THEIR FIVE YEAR CAPITAL PLAN
AND AS THINGS MOVE FORWARD AS
YOU KNOW THESE THINGS DON'T
HAPPEN.
OVERNIGHT SO THERE IS A PROCESS
THAT THEY'LL GO THROUGH TO MAKE
THESE CHOICES ABOUT HOW IS IT.
IS IT EARTHQUAKE RETROFITTING IS
IT A NEW A LABORATORY THAT
STOPPING KIDS FROM GETTING
SCIENCE DEGREES THEY'LL MAKE
THESE THOUGHTFUL CHOICES.
I IN A DELIBERATE OF WAY IT'S
NOT PRESCRIPTIVE IN THE BILL
THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DR ROMA.
THANK YOU SENATOR I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY AND MOVE
THIS BILL MISTER CHAIR WHILE I
DON'T HAVE A CSU OR YOU SEE AND
MY DISTRICT I DO HAVE A CITY
COLLEGE WHICH I'M QUITE PROUD OF
AN ANSWER FOR CITY COLLEGE.
BUT I'M SUPPORTING THIS BECAUSE
I TOOK A TOUR WITH OUR CSU
PRESIDENT AT FRESNO STATE.
AND I SAW THEIR CENTRAL CORE
POWER PLANT AND THE COMPUTER
THAT OPERATED IT.
STILL HAS AN OPERATING SYSTEM
AND HAD A FLOPPY DISK DRIVE FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO.
KNOW ABOUT THAT AND THEY HAD TO
FIND A LOT OF THEIR REPLACEMENTS
ON EBAY BECAUSE THE PRODUCER NO
LONGER IS IN SUPPLY THAT'S HOW
LONG OUR FACILITIES HAVE NEEDED
THIS UPGRADE AND WHY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS.
TODAY IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO
BE REINVESTED IN AND WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS.
THANK YOU AND AND AND AND
PRESIDENT CASTRO WAS A VERY
ARTICULATE ADVOCATE FOR FRESNO
STATE AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
IT'S NOT SENATOR BOARD JUST.
HAS JOINED IN DIE AND CO AUTHOR
IN THIS LEGISLATION FOR THAT
VERY REASON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
MR GABER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THIS
PROJECT.
YOU'VE DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB
HERE I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT BILLS WE HAVE A
FOR THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR
AND JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
AND WOOD -- SECOND THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK -- THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING IN THIS MEASURE
FORWARD AND I'M ALSO THANKFUL TO
BE A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU.
AS I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VISIT A MANY OF THE CAMPUSES I
INCLUDING SACKS STATE WHERE I
SAW JUST THE VERY THING THAT YOU
MENTIONED -- LABORATORY THAT IS
A BOTTLENECK FOR STUDENTS A
LABORATORY THAT SOLD -- THAT IT
CAN'T OF THE COMEDY OF THE
STUDENTS WHO NEED THAT SCIENCE
CLASS IN THAT SCIENCE LAB.
IN ORDER TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THEIR DEGREES -- IT ALSO UC
RIVERSIDE THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT AS IT BEGINS TO GROW
IT AS IT BEGINS TO ACCOMMODATE
MORE AND MORE STUDENTS.
I HEAR STORIES OF STUDENTS
SITTING ON THE FLOOR OF NOT
BEING ENOUGH -- DEATHS.
OF NOT BEING NOT ENOUGH OFFICE
SPACE OF FOR NEW FACULTY.
SO FOR FOR ALL THOSE REASONS --
I THINK VERY MUCH THIS IS. FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
SENATOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND CO
SPONSORSHIP OF THIS MEASURE AND
I'M I'M VERY PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT.
IT'S A BIPARTISAN BILL BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
OUR PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS DID
THAT FOR US IN THE KIDS OF TODAY
WE NEED TO DO THAT FOR THE
FUTURE.
AND I THINK THIS BILL OUT WILL
ALLOW THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
HOPEFULLY TO MAKE A GOOD CHOICE
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
AND MADAM SECRETARY READ PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NOT VOTING LEVINE LEVINE I
LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HI.
THE BILL IS A NINE ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND THEN
WE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM.
TO SB.
ONE FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
SB ONE FORTY EIGHT WOULD CREATE
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM.
THAT PROMISE PROGRAM WENT INTO
EFFECT IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HE GAVE
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS THE TOOLS TO DO SO.
SO FAR NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND
STUDENTS HAVE PARTICIPATED --
THE PREVIOUS BILL ALSO REQUIRED
THE STATE UNIVERSITIES TO SUBMIT
A REPORT WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ON
POTENTIAL INCENTIVES THAT ARE
CUTTING.
ENCOURAGE STUDENT PARTICIPATION
IN THE PROMISE PROGRAM -- IN
THAT REPORT THE STATE
UNIVERSITIES NOTED QUOTE
EFFECTIVE INCENTIVES COULD
ENCOURAGE MORE STUDENTS TO KEEP
PACE WITH THEIR COMMITMENTS.
AND COULD SERVE AS A MEANS TO
ATTRACT MORE STUDENTS TO COMMIT
TO THESE PROGRAMS AT THE ONSET.
OF THEIR ACADEMIC CAREER.
FIND QUOTE SO BUILDING UPON
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
BILL IS THAT BEFORE YOU -- IT
WOULD ESTABLISH THE STUDENT
SUCCESS IN ON TIME COMPLETION
FIND BUT ALLOW MONEY
APPROPRIATED TO THIS FUND BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE USED FOR
SUMMER GRANTS.
ON TRACK PROGRESS GRANTS.
AND STARTING ON JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY PROVIDE BACK IN
TUITION WAIVERS FOR ALL
REMAINING CLASSES NEEDED TO
GRADUATE WHEN A CAMPUS IS UNABLE
TO PROVIDE A PATHWAY TO GRADUATE.
IN FOUR OR TWO YEARS.
IN PARTICULAR THIS BILL PROVIDES
INCENTIVES TO STUDENTS IN NEED
TO REQUIREMENT UNDER THE BILL
THAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AND THEY ARE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AND FINALLY THE CSU WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CHOOSE WHICH AND
SENATOR USED AT EACH INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUS PROGRAM.
AND THE MONEY -- THE BILL
SPECIFIES THAT MONEY IN THIS NEW
FUND MAY BE USED BY THE TRUSTEES
TO CREATE THE INCENTIVES NOTHING
REQUIRES THE TRUSTEES TO DO THIS.
I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE TODAY AND
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS HANNAH BRAG STAT.
OF REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION
[inaudible]
SECOND.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HANNAH BACK
START WITH THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THANKFUL FOR
SENATOR GLAZER FOR THE WORK HE'S
DONE ON SB.
ONE FOUR EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM. FOUR YEARS AGO
WHEN SENATOR GLAZER BROUGHT THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISED BUILT OUR
BOARD CSSA OPPOSE THE BILL AT
THE TIME WE FELT LIKE THE
TUITION FREEZE AS WELL AS THE
IDEA THE ONLY PRIVILEGE STUDENTS
COULD ACCESS THE PROGRAM.
DID NOT HAVE STUDENT EQUITY AT
THE HEART OF THE PROGRAM MAKING
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO ONLY
THOSE STUDENTS WITH THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY TO TAKE THEM
IS NOT AN ACQUITTAL EQUITABLE
SOLUTION TO US.
MANY STUDENTS HAVE TO WORK
MULTIPLE JOBS TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND MANY TIMES THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS CSU STUDENTS WITH
SUCH A HIGH LEVEL OF POWERS THAT
BEYONCE FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AN UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS EQUITY IS AN APP
SALUTE PRIORITY FOR US.
IT'S AN ARE VERY MISSION AS AN
ORGANIZATION THIS IS WHY WE ARE
SO APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE ON SB ONE FOUR
EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZER AND HIS
STAFF TO COME UP WITH INCENTIVES
TO ENABLE ALL STUDENTS A GOOD
FAITH OPPORTUNITY. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE PROGRAMS WITH
THE ADDED INCENTIVES SUMMER TERM
GRANTS ON TRUCK PROPER PROGRESS
GRANTS TO OFFSET NON TUITION
COSTS AND NO TUITION CHARGE FOR
STUDENTS WHO TAKE LONGER THAN
FOUR YEARS DUE TO INSTITUTIONAL
FAULT.
THE BILL NOW ADDRESSES MANY OF
OUR CONCERNS REGARDING EQUITY.
GOING TO COLLEGE HAS A NUMBER OF
BENEFITS FOR STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY IN THE CAL STATE
STUDENT SYSTEM.
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR UPWARD
SOCIAL MOBILITY IS CHIEF AMONG
THEM THIS PERSPECTIVE IS
SUPPORTED BY RESEARCH THAT I
SHOWN MANY CAL STATE.
CAMPUSES ARE THE NATIONAL
LEADERS ON ENABLING UPWARD
SOCIAL MOBILITY CAL STATE LA AS
THE NUMBER ONE INSTITUTION TO DO
THIS.
BUT THIS BENEFIT IS NEVER
REALIZED AND STUDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY WORSE OFF IF THEY
CANNOT GRADUATE.
IF THE STATE CREATES PROGRAMS
THAT HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE
QUICKER EVEN SMALLER SUBSET
STUDENTS THAT HAS AN IMPACT ON
ALL STUDENTS.
SIMPLY PUT GRADUATING STUDENTS
QUICKER OPENS UP COURSE BASED
ACROSS THE BOARD AS WELL AS
ENROLLMENT SLOTS SB ONE FOUR
EIGHT SIX DO YOU JUSTICE NOW
WITH THE INCENTIVES INCLUDED NOT
ONLY WILL THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM BE SEEN BY ALL STUDENTS
IN THE SYSTEM.
BUT NOW THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PERSONALLY PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM IS OPEN TO ALL STUDENTS
WE THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS AND DRIVE VOTE
TODAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WESTON SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE MR
GABLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO CENTER
I JUST -- WANNA MAKE SURE
UNDERSTAND OUR WEEK.
NARROWING THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
THE COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM.
UNDER THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN IT WOULD DO THAT YES
OKAY AND WHAT I'M JUST CAN YOU
SPELL THAT OUT A LITTLE BIT TO
SORT OF WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE IN THE RATIONALE FOR
NARROWING IT.
WELL THE THE RATIONALE WOULD
ONLY BE IN THE EYE OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR --
PLACE THIS AMENDMENT IN THE BILL --
BUT IT DOES LIMIT THE
ELIGIBILITY -- AND THAT WILL
AFFECT THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO WILL CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROMISE PROGRAM GOING
FORWARD UNDER THE BILL AS
WRITTEN TODAY OKAY AND YOU HAVE
A SENSE OF WHAT THE NUMBER WHAT
WHAT THAT BEING IN THE NUMBER
STUDENTS THAT.
PREVIOUSLY WOULD HAVE BEEN
ELIGIBLE FOR COLLEGE PROMISE AND
NOW WILL NO LONGER BE ELIGIBLE
FOR IT -- UNDER THAT THAT
NUMBERS THAT I'VE GOTTEN OF THE
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT
HAVE -- ARE PARTICIPATING TODAY
IN THE PROGRAM -- THAT
APPROXIMATELY -- 40% GOING
FORWARD IF THE PROGRAM HAD BEEN.
UNDER THOSE TERMS HAVE BEEN
CREATED. TWO YEARS AGO WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN IT
THAT TODAY -- SO THERE THAT THAT
THAT THAT AND THAT IS OBVIOUSLY
A POINT OF A DISAPPOINTMENT.
OKAY I WELL I AND I APPRECIATE
THE CANTOR HADN'T REALIZED THAT
THAT HAD BEEN THE TRAJECTORY THE
LEGISLATION I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT AND INTENT
OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
I GUESS I YOU KNOW IN A I I
THINK I PROBABLY AGREE WITH YOU.
THAT IN A IN A IN A PERFECT
WORLD IT WOULD BE NICE FOR THIS
PROGRAM TO BE FOR ALL FOR ALL
STUDENTS AT AT CSU TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY EXCESSES PROGRAM.
I AGREE THANK YOU.
SEE NOOTHER QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
ISSUE OF GRADUATION RATES HAS
BEEN.
A PASSION OF MINE SINCE I WAS A
PUT ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND
THEN OUT AND AND AND SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE.
I WE HAS SO MANY GREAT CAMPUS
LEADERS AND GREAT FACULTY WHO
DOING SUCH GREAT WORK FOR OUR
STUDENTS BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
OUR FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATES
IT'S IT'S A POINT OF GREAT
DISAPPOINTMENT OF ALL OF US
CURRENTLY IT IT'S ABOUT 4424%.
FOR THE THE STATE UNIVERSITIES
24% GET THROUGH IN FOUR YEARS.
AND THE SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE
HOVERS A LITTLE UNDER 60% NOW
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE SYSTEM
RECOGNIZES THE PROBLEM AND
THEY'VE SET SOME VERY AMBITIOUS
GOALS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE US TO
ACHIEVE BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
GET 240%.
OFF FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATE
WITH NO DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN
UNDER REPRESENTED AT THE
STUDENTS THAT I THINK THAT IS
EXCELLENT AND THAT'S GREAT
LEADERSHIP.
IT REQUIRES A PARTNERSHIP ALL OF
US TOGETHER IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN THAT IN THE POLICY
CHOICES THAT WE'RE MAKING HERE
TODAY -- BUT IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WE CAN DO
TO NOT JUST PROVIDE -- ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY AND QUALITY
BUT STUDENT COMPLETION IF WE
DON'T HAVE THAT FOURTH LEG TO
THE CHAIR WE'RE NOT DOING OUR
WORK WELL AND I THINK THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL FOCUSES ON AND I
KNOW MANY PEOPLE AROUND THAT.
DAY AS HERE IS HAVE THAT JOIN ME
IN TRYING TO GET THAT ATTENTION
TOOK STUDENT COMPLETION AT MONTH
EVERYTHING ELSE IS EQUAL.
AND AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO ADVANCE TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
WE HAD A FIRST BY MR GABRIEL.
SECOND BY [inaudible]
MR LOW.
AND A THIRD THAT LITTLE.
WELL THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUING
EFFORT ON SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT -- I SHARE
YOUR YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION.
RATE LAST YEAR THE COMMITTEE
PASSED SB.
THREE FORTY SIX AND THOUGH WE
DID RAISE QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE TUITION FREEZE AND OUR
STUDENTS QUALIFIED FOR AID.
THIS BILL SB ONE FORTY EIGHT HAS
BEEN CHANGED TO REFLECT.
THOSE QUESTIONS AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO WE HAD THE
MOTION AND BY.
DR RUMBLE -- SECOND BY MISTER
LOWE AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I TEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR SB.
TWO NINETY SIX SENATOR ALLEN.
NOT OKAY WE WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM.
FIVE SB THREE FIFTY FOUR SENATOR
TWO ROWS OF WELCOME
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE --
TODAY I'LL BE TALKING ABOUT SB --
THREE FIVE FOUR WHICH WILL
EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM TO UC AND CSU GRADUATE
STUDENTS.
THAT MEET THE A. B. FIVE FORTY
REQUIREMENTS.
UP THE LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST
OF THIS TO BE COMMENDED FOR ITS
WORK ON SB TWELVE TEN WHICH
CREATED.
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS A RESOURCE TO FUND
THEIR UNDERGRADUATE.
EDUCATION I WOULD LIKE FOR US TO
CONTINUE THIS PROGRESS AND ALLOW
YOU.
AND CSU TO USE EXISTING DREAM
LOAN FUNDS. TO OFFER LOANS FOR
GRADUATE STUDENTS THE ALSO MEET
AB FIVE FORTY REQUIREMENTS.
IF THIS BILL IS PASSED IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT FIVE HUNDRED
GRADUATE STUDENTS IN THE UC AND
CSU COMBINED WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THIS BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF
BOTH THE UC AND CSU SEGMENTS AS
WELL AS SUPPORT. FOR BENNY
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS.
I HOPE TODAY WE CAN HAVE ALL OF
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
AND MOVE OUR STATE CLOSER
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS -- AND TODAY IS A
WITNESS I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ THE POLICY
ADVOCATE. FOR THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CHRIS FOR SIGNS OF A TRAILER THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
YOUTH ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA JIM NETWORK -- PROUD
TO BE SPONSORS THIS MEASURE --
THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS WHY
THIS BILL CAME OF TO TO LIE ONE
IS A FROM DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR
MEMBERS A LOT OF THEM WERE
SAYING AFTER WENT ONCE THEY
ATTENDED GRADUATE SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ENTERED INTO AN
EDUCATIONAL PATHWAY.
TOWARDS A PROGRAM THAT REQUIRE
THEM TO GO TO GRADUATE SCHOOL
FOR NOT TO BE DOLLARS AND SOME
OF THE UNIVERSITY GRANTS WERE
NOT AVAILABLE TO THEM BECAUSE
THEY FOCUSED ON UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS.
ONCE THE STUDENTS WOULD SEEK OUT
LOANS MOST THE TIME THERE WOULD
BE BARRED OUT OF TRADITIONAL
STUDENT LOANS BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF STATUS AND WOOD.
OM ONLY HAVE THE OPTION OF
OBTAINING HIGH INTEREST RATE
LOANS WHICH WOULD TYPICALLY
BRING THEM TO TRIPLE DIGIT
INTEREST RATES.
ARE THEREFORE -- WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A VERY LOW COST
AFFORDABLE ALL ALONE FOR
GRADUATE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ON EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS TOWARDS GRADUATE
EDUCATION WHICH IS A LOAN THAT
THEY WOULD REPAY.
ON ONCE THEY COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI JAKE BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
AND THE CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED
HIGHER EDUCATION COALITION THAT
WE FACILITATE IN SUPPORT THANK.
HELLO PORTION WAS FRIENDLY WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
HI TYLER REGULAR BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MERRY WASHINGTON WITH CASSIE
SINICIZATION IN SUPPORT.
ERICA ROMERO WITH THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
DEEPLY AGNESE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN'S IS ALREADY MARIAH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND SUPPORT WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
DEDICATION TO OUR AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS.
CHECK A FREIGHTER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WHEN THE WONDER WHAT CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT?
NEIL SWEENEY A W. HIGHER
EDUCATION LOCALS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL I I'D LIKE.
TO THANK SENATOR DORADO -- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
AS YOU VERY.
EXCUSE ME ELOQUENTLY SAID WHEN I
BROUGHT A BILL.
IN IN THE SAME AREA TO THE
SENATE -- EDUCATION COMMITTEE WE
CONTINUE TO CHIP AWAY.
AND AND I HOPE THAT I AGREE WITH
YOU I HOPE THAT WE GET TO THE
DAY WHERE WE WANT HAVE TO BE
MAKING.
INCREMENTAL CHANGES TO THE LAW
BUT THAT WE WILL.
DO WHAT OUR VALUES THAT WE SAY
WE WE DO AND EMBRACE ALL
STUDENTS AND IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
A WE HAD A MOTION.
BY DOCTOR RUMBULA A SECOND BY
MISTER LOWE AND MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I A ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES.
MOVED TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHT SB.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN SENATOR OF
MINING IS HERE.
DO NOT SEE HIM.
SO WE ARE.
WAITING FOR AUTHORS [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
WE MOVED.
A SECOND THAT.
OKAY.
DOCTOR WEBER MOVE THE CONSENT
ITEMS.
SECOND BY MISTER LEVINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I TEN ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OF APPROVED AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND INVITE CENTER MONEY -- FILE
ITEM EIGHT SB.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON.
AS THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN FOOD AND
SECURITY CONTINUES TO RISE.
THE CSU AND YOU SEE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WITH
ACCURATE ESTIMATES FOR THE COST
OF ATTENDING THEIR SCHOOLS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE NINETY AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ WHICH NOW
REQUIRES THE C. ISSUE WHEN YOU
SEE THE POST ON THEIR INTERNET
WEBSITES.
THE ESTIMATED MARKET COST OF AN
OFF CAMPUS ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT.
WELL THIS WAS A GOOD FIRST STEP
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS COULD
BENEFIT MORE FROM COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION ON THE EXPENSES THEY
WILL FACE.
WHEN THEY IN RURAL?
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND REQUESTS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. TO
PLACE ON THEIR WEBSITES THE
COMPREHENSIVE COST OF ATTENDANCE
INCLUDING THE CURRENT COST OF AN
OFF CAMPUS TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT.
IN A SINGLE BEDROOM IN A PRIVATE
HOME FOR PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS
THIS BILL EMPOWERS PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS TO MAKE FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS.
WHEN REVIEWING A PERSPECTIVE SEE
ISSUE OR YOU SEE?
MEMBERS I'D ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR
I HAVE. TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TODAY SHAUNA LYNCH OF CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY CAL POLY.
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO AND BRETT
RAFFISH ALSO COMPANY STATE
UNIVERSITY CAL POLY.
THANK YOU.
LOOK AT THE SECOND.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN INDIANA AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS FOR HAVING US
TODAY WE APPRECIATE SENATOR
MINING INVITING US TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHANE A LYNCH AND I'M
A SECOND YEAR POLITICAL SCIENCE
STUDENT AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO ORIGINALLY FROM SAN JOSE
AND I'M SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF SP.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THIS YEAR I
SERVICE THE STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE ON OUR
UNIVERSITIES BASIC NEEDS TASK
FORCE.
AND THIS COMMITTEE WE WORK TO
PROVIDE HELP TO THE 27% OF CAL
POLY STUDENTS WHO EXPERIENCED
FOOD INSECURITY AND 12% WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS.
CSU AND YOU SEE DATA ACROSS THE
BOARD SHOWS 42% FOOD AND
SECURITY AMONG STUDENTS WHICH
INDICATES THAT COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE AFFECTED THREE TIMES AS MUCH
AS NON SOON HOUSEHOLDS.
HOMELESSNESS ON THE OTHER HAND
AFFECTS ABOUT 13% OF STUDENTS
BUT HAS BEEN REPORTED AS HIGH AS
20% IN THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
WELL THERE ARE TYPICALLY ALREADY
UNIVERSITY COMMITTEES THAT WORK
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE STUDENTS
NEED TO BE INFORMED OF COLLEGE
COSTS.
THANK COMPASS MORE OF WHAT THEY
EXPERIENCE IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR EQUIPPED WITH THE
TOOLS TO PLAN FOR THE FINANCIAL
BURDENS OF COLLEGE ACCORDINGLY.
THE ADDRESSING THE ISSUE AT HAND
THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE
EDUCATION CODE WILL HELP CHRIS
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH THESE MORE
TRANSPARENT COLLEGE COST
ESTIMATES.
REQUESTING FOR CS USE AN UC'S TO
INCLUDE THE SAME BREAKDOWN OF
PRICES.
THE BILL ENSURES THAT STUDENTS
HAVE A STANDARDIZED FIGURE TO
COMPARE WHEN CHOOSING BETWEEN
COLLEGES.
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN EXPANDS ON
CURRENT CODE BY PROVIDING
ESTIMATES THAT ARE ENCOMPASSING
OVERVIEW THAT'S APPLICABLE TO
WHAT SEEMS TYPICALLY EXPERIENCE.
THIS LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCESSIBILITY AND CONSISTENCY
WITH LINE PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS
UP FOR SUCCESSFUL FINANCIAL
PLANNING WHEN DETERMINING WHICH
UNIVERSITY IS THE BEST FIT FOR
THEIR FINANCIAL LIMITS.
BUT MORE ACCURATE PLANNING
STUDENTS AND SUPPORTERS WILL BE
ABLE TO MINIMIZE THE HARSH
EXTERNALITIES OF CURRENT
PRACTICES.
THANK YOU AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AN
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BRETT RAFFISH AND I'M A
FOURTH YOUR POLITICAL SCIENCE
STUDENT AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO.
WITH TWO PARENTS WERE CSU
NORTHRIDGE GRADUATES AND A
SISTER WAS A CURRENT SAN DIEGO
STATE STUDENT.
I'M IMMENSELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM HAS
PROVIDED ME AND MY FAMILY.
ALTHOUGH THE COST OF ATTENDING A
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITY HAS
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGED FROM MY
PARENTS GENERATION OF MINE.
THE STRESSES HAVE REMAINED
REMARKABLY CONSISTENT.
EXAMS A PAPER DEADLINES OR SOME
OF THE INHERENT STRESSES THAT
ACCOMPANY THE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
UNLIKE MANY OF THE NORMAL
STRESSES THE COLLEGE STUDENTS
OFTEN EXPERIENCE.
HOMELESSNESS FOOD INSECURITY IN
CRIPPLING DEBT FALL STARK WOULD
BE ON THE SPECTRUM NORMALCY.
AFFORDABILITY HAS LONG BEEN ONE
OF THE PRINCIPAL BARRIERS TO
CALIFORNIA SEEKING ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION.
IN THIS BILL ACTIVELY SIX TO
REMEDY ONE ASPECT OF THIS ISSUE.
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN DOES SO
THROUGH FOUR DIFFERENT
PROVISIONS THE BILL FIRST
SUPPLEMENTS THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS THE UNIVERSITY'S
DISPLAY THE COST OF A ONE
BEDROOM APARTMENT.
BY MANDATING THE UNIVERSITY BY
MANDATING THAT UNIVERSITIES
DISPLAY THE ESTIMATED COST OF A
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IN THE
COST OF A ROOM IN A HOUSE FOR
THE BILL IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
INVOLVING COST ESTIMATE
DERIVATION.
BY REQUIRING THAT UNIVERSITIES
POSTED DESCRIPTION OF THE
METHODS AND DATA SOURCES USED TO
DERIVE COST ESTIMATES.
THIRD THE BILL MANDATES THAT
UNIVERSITIES DISPLAY COST
ESTIMATES INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED.
TO HOUSING FOOD AND
TRANSPORTATION ON THE SAME WEB
PAGE.
AND LASTLY THE BILL MANDATES
THAT UNIVERSITIES EMPHASIZE THAT
THE PROJECTED COST ESTIMATE IS
IN FACT AN ESTIMATE.
IN A PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TO CONSULT MULTIPLE
SOURCES TO ENSURE THAT THEY GAIN
A MORE COMPLETE PICTURE OF THE
PERSPECTIVE COST OF ATTENDANCE
AT A CALIFORNIA DIVERSITY.
IT IS A TRUISM TO CLAIM THE
COLLEGE IS STRESSFUL.
ENSURING THAT YOUR FINANCIAL
LATER LOANS WILL COVER YOUR
WEEKLY GROCERY EXPENSES OR YOUR
MONTHLY RENT.
OUR STRESSES THAT OF WATCH THEIR
WAY INTO THE SPECTRUM NORMALCY.
BUT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
ANYTHING BUT NORMAL.
WE POLITELY REQUEST IN WOULD BE
IMMENSELY GRATEFUL FOR THIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TIME.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PAIGE
LOGAN A STUDENT AND A MEMBER OF
THIS BILL PARK PROJECT WRITING
CLASS AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO.
BILLY BARTON ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE COUPLE THE BUILD WRITING
CLASS -- STRONG SUPPORT.
MY WASH NOR CAL STATE SOON
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE PROUD TO
COSPONSOR THIS BILL.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
PUSH OF ASSEMBLY WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN NONE I THANK THE STUDENTS
OF CAL POLY POMONA.
AND THEIR WORK WITH OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE.
CAPTURE.
OF REPRESENTATIVE SAN LUIS
OBISPO FOR THEIR WORK --
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
AND FOR THEIR INVOLVEMENT AND I
HOPE -- THE PROCESS IS -- BEEN A
LEARNING EXPERIENCE AND I FORGOT
TO ASK SAID THE CENTER FEED LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSE VERY BRIEFLY.
I TOO WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUT CHOSE
SIDE JIAN WHO'S BEEN WORKING
WITH THIS STUDENT PROJECT TO CAL
POLY.
AND ALSO THEIR COMPANY TODAY THE
STUDENTS BY PROFESSOR CHRIS DâN
HARTOG WANT TO THANK HIM FOR HIS
WORK WITH.
INTRODUCING STUDENTS TO HOW
GOVERNMENT WORKS IN
PARTICIPATING IN IT SO WITH THAT
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FEAR I VOTE.
AND AND I I DO ONE OF JUST ONE
CAVEA.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD --
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORTED BUT ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ADVANTAGES AS A BILL
THAT IS ALSO MOVING FORWARD
SOMEWHAT SIMILAR -- SO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO WORK WITH C. S. A. C. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AS
THIS BILL WAS FOR EIGHT LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT THANK YOU FOR
THE HEADS UP SO WE HAD A MOTION
BY MISTER LOW AND A SECOND BY DR
ARAMBULA.
AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
APRIL I IRWIN.
KILEY.
KILEY I LEVINE LEVINE I LOW LOW
I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER II. NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOVE TO ITEM FOR SENATOR
ALLEN SB.
TWO NINETY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO THINK THAT COMMITTEE FOR
ITS WORK ON THE BILL -- THIS
BILL.
TAKES CARE OF OF ONE LITTLE BUT
IMPORTANT PROBLEM -- THAT EXISTS
IN OUR CURRENT FINANCIALLY
SYSTEM.
IT -- IT BASICALLY.
MAKES IT SO THAT FOR THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE -- THOSE WHO ARE HERE
SEEKING ASYLUM.
WHO ALREADY HAVE A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER AND A WORK
PERMIT -- BUT FOR OTHER REASONS
ARE NOT CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR
CAL GRANT OR AB.
FIVE FORTY IT MAKES THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANT.
IT'S A SMALL PORTION OF OF THE
POPULATION HI BUT THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVE WORK STATUS
RIGHT NOW.
IN CALIFORNIA AS THEY AWAIT
THEIR ASYLUM DECISION AND WE
WANT TO GIVE THEM ACCESS TO
EDUCATION SO THEY CAN CONTINUE
WITH THEIR LIFE -- AND I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY DAVID O'BRIEN FOR
THE CALIFORNIANS TO NEED
COMMISSION ALSO ADAM A TOUGHIE
FROM THE ACCOUNT YOU SEE
CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
AND AND RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS DAVID
O'BRIEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT A COMMISSION IN SUPPORT
OF THIS COMMONSENSE MEASURE --
AS YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WE
ALREADY HAVE FAR TOO MANY
BARRIERS TO STUDENTS --
RECEIVING FINANCIAL AID IN OUR
SYSTEM ALREADY -- THIS BILL
REMOVES ONE OF THOSE BARRIERS --
TO A RELATIVELY SMALL BUT
POPULATION BUT A POPULATION THAT
HAS FOR TOO LONG BEEN OVERLOOKED.
AND COULD REALLY BENEFIT FROM
THIS AID SO -- WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AND HAVE HER HAPPY
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS YOU HAVE --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS ADAM HOW
TO FEE AND I AM HERE -- I'M A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS I AM ALSO
UNITED STATES PERMANENT RESIDENT
BY THE WAY OF ASYLUM I WENT
THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN BEHALF OF A
SPEAK TO NINETY SIX OF FOR TWO
REASONS -- SUCCESS IN TODAY'S
WORLD IS HIGHLY IMPLAUSIBLE
WITHOUT A COLLEGE DEGREE.
AND THE PROCESS OF THE OBTAINING
ASYLUM IS A HARD AND LONG.
ONE AND IT TAKES AWHILE.
TO YIELD RESULTS BUT PEOPLE LIKE
ME AND MY FAMILY COME TO THIS
COUNTRY LOOKING FOR A BETTER
LIFE.
AND WE COME HERE WITH NOTHING NO
MONEY NO.
PRETTY NO CAPITAL WHEN WE FIRST
ARRIVED IN THE UNITED STATES.
MY PARENTS AND I HAVE TO STAY
WITH RELATIVES.
IN FOUR WEEKS UNTIL WE FOUND A
SMALL APARTMENT WE COULD AFFORD
I WAS SIXTEEN THEN.
IT TOOK US YEARS TO PUT HER LIFE
BACK TOGETHER -- I COULD NOT
IMAGINE WHAT WE WOULD HAVE DONE
IF WE HAVE TO PAY FOR TUITION
WHEN WE FIRST ARRIVED HERE.
AT THE COST OF ATTENDANCE AT A
YOU SEE AS THE TO TO YOU SEE AS
A NON RESIDENT WHEN YOU.
FIRST GET HERE AND YOU'RE GOING
TO COLLEGE AND HE JUST GOT HERE
FROM A DIFFERENT COUNTRY -- BUT
YOU ARE NOT RESIDENT IN THE COST
OF ATTENDANCE AS WELL OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR NON
RESIDENT AND THAT'S WELL OVER WE
HAD WHEN WE FIRST GOT HERE.
I AM ABLE TO BE HERE IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY BECAUSE I'M LUCKY
ENOUGH TO NOT TO HAVE TO WORK
TWO JOBS IN ORDER TO PAY.
FOR A SCHOOL RENT AND FOOD WHEN
THIS BILL WAS IN FRONT OF THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
A FRIEND OF MINE TOLD THE STORY
OF HOW HE HAS BEEN WAITING FOR
HIS ASYLUM TO BE PROCESSED FOR
FIVE YEARS.
AND HOW HE HAS HAD TO PAY FOR
HIMSELF ATTENDED A YOU SEE WHILE
SUPPORTING HIMSELF UNABLE TO
FOCUS ON IS EDUCATION NOW THE
FACT OF THE MATTER.
IS THAT MANY OTHERS LIKE ME WHO
HAVE WHO HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
SENATE PROCESS ARE NOT ABLE TO
TAKE THE TIME OUT OF THEIR LIVES
TO TELL YOU THIS THAT WE COME
HERE TO THE UNITED STATES AND
THE CALIFORNIA LOOKING FOR A
BETTER FUTURE.
MANY OF US ESCAPE OPPRESSION
VIOLENCE AND THREATS TO OUR
LIVES.
MY PARENTS AND I FLIP FROM IRAN
DUE TO THE THREAT OF POLITICAL
PROSPERS OCCASION.
AND WE CAME HERE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
FIND A BETTER FUTURE FOR OUR
FAMILY.
WE CAME HERE WITH VERY LITTLE
MANY COME HERE WITH NOTHING --
AND IN THIS ENTRY SIX AS A
SIMPLY NOT POSSIBLE WITHOUT A
COLLEGE EDUCATION.
OUR SUCCESS CONTRIBUTES TO THE
STATE INTO THIS COUNTRY BUT WE
CANNOT DO THAT WITHOUT AN
EDUCATION.
AND WE CANNOT GET AN EDUCATION
IF WE HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN A
ROOF OVER OUR HEADS.
A MEAL IN OUR STOMACH OR
ATTENDING TOMORROW'S LECTURE.
THIS WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
THOSE OF US WHO WEREN'T AS LUCKY
AS I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET
HERE WHILE I WAS STILL IN HIGH
SCHOOL -- TO GET AN EDUCATION
AND TO SUCCEED -- AND SO I ASK
YOU TODAY TO PASS AS WELL -- SO
THAT THEY ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE OF THE SOME HELP IN
ACHIEVING.
A BETTER LIFE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL STATE
SINICIZATION IN SUPPORT.
QUESTION IS PROBABLY WITH THE UC
SAN A SAUSAGE AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
CHECK OF REGULAR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK OUT
FOR A CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEEPLY AGNETHA CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAL GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT STRONG AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX CASE THE
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES
AND SUPPORT.
REYES A FERNANDEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT.
REAL SWEET MEALS MANY YOU A W.
HIGHER EDUCATION LOCALS IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
YEAH I'D APPRECIATE -- THE THE
STRONG SUPPORT FROM FROM ALL
FOLKS WE GOT A STRONG BIPARTISAN
VOTE FOR THIS ON THE SENATE SIDE
AND I I YOU KNOW I I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE -- PEOPLE SUPPORT.
FOR FOR PREVENT -- FOR FOR
PROVIDING -- FOR THIS IMPORTANT
AVENUE FOR ACCESS TO EDUCATION
FOR A SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
PORTION OF OUR OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE'S POPULATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRING IN
THE BILL FORWARD WE HAD A MOTION
BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA.
OF MADAM SECRETARY READ PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER HI.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
EIGHT ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WILL MOVE NOW TO ITEM.
NINE SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX SENATOR
ROTH [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE TWO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS PRESENTED BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK MISTER CHAIR YOUR
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THIS BILL.
IT'S A RATHER SIMPLE BILL THE
RESPONSE TO CONCERNS RAISED AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING -- THAT
WAS CONDUCTED ON CAREER
TECHNOLOGY IN THE NEW ECONOMY --
DOWN IN RIVERSIDE NOT TOO LONG
AGO AT THAT HEARING -- I HEARD
FROM A VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS
CONCERNING.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE GROWING NEED
FOR SKILLED LABOR TO MEET LOCAL
INDUSTRY EMPLOYMENT GROWTH SO
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN BY.
FRANKLY SIMPLY PROVIDING A FORUM
FOR THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH COMPANY COULD
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS THEY DEVELOP
THEIR COLLEGE.
AND CAREER ACCESS PROGRAMS I
BELIEVE THIS BILL COMPLIMENTS
OTHER EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN.
PUT THROUGH IN THE PAST AND THAT
ARE CURRENTLY ON GOING IN WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NO
WITNESSES ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
THAT WOULD HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR CHOI A SECOND BY DOCTOR
WEBER -- COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BY THE COMMITTEE.
DR RUMBLE.
I'M QUITE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE TODAY I JUST.
ALWAYS HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
CONCERN WHEN IT WE MAY BE ADDING
ANOTHER STEP BY.
REQUIRING THE COLLABORATION AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCAL WAR
COURSE BOARDS AND WE JUST HOPE
THAT -- THE PREVIOUS MEASURE
THAT THIS BODY VOTED ON A. B.
THIRTY AND TO YOURSELF OR ABLE
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION BUT AGAIN
HAPPY TO MOVE IT FORWARD TODAY
THIS COLLABORATION IS IMPORTANT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR CHOI.
SENATOR I'M VERY MUCH INTERESTED
IN OUR OUR OWN DISAPPEARANCE.
OF THIS IS OUR FIRST TAP -- THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- TO DEVELOP
A STRONG A CAREER TECHNICAL LAW
NOW TRACK.
I EVERY E. ARM NOW TREE.
ORGANIZATIONS SO.
THE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF OCCUR.
DETECT CARRIERS SIDE SELECT A
ELECTRICIANS SO A TRUCK DRIVERS
SO.
ALL ALL DIFFERENT.
TYPES OF OF A CAREER.
TECHNICAL.
SIDE OF A TRADE THAT THE ALL OF
TOLD ME.
THEY ARE SUFFERING.
IN RECRUITING -- THE WORK FORCE.
SO CONSULTING.
OUT WITH THE OUT WORKFORCE --
BOARD IS A GOOD THING SO THAT
THEY CAN CREATE THE RIGHT
PROGRAM SAID THEO COMMITTEE
COTTAGES SO BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO COME UP WITH THE SOME.
ZHOU WE CAN.
ATTRACT THE FROM THE BEGINNING.
OF MORE FUTURE WORK FOR SO --
BASED UPON PAYROLL -- THAILAND
SO WHAT AT TWO TWO RATHER THAN --
RATHER THAN AT THE LAST MINUTE
THE PEOPLE ON THE STREET IN
ORDER TO COPE TO COME TO THAT --
TRADE SO I THINK THAT THIS IS A
BEGINNING OF THAT THE STEP BY
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU AND THEN
ALSO WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE FOR THAT KIND OF EDUCATION
MORE STRONGER.
EDUCATION PROGRAM AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE -- THE SENATOR FOR
BRING IN THE BILL FORWARD -- AS
A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER HAD LOTS
OF EXPERIENCE -- WITH THE DUAL
ENROLLMENT AND KNOW THE THE
VALUE OF DUAL ENROLLMENT FOR FOR
ALL STUDENTS -- WOULD ECHO -- MY
COLLEAGUE.
FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY --
TO PLEASE CONTINUE WORKING IN --
WAS CENTER FOR WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN WHO HAD A A
PREVIOUS BILL -- TO STREAMLINE
COULD YOU TO TO DO THAT SO WE
HAD A MEASURE BY A DOCTOR CHOI
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER AND I'M
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM
[inaudible]
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY I LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER.
WEBER I TEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
.
OKAY ADELINES ITEM ONE SB
FOURTEEN PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO HI. TEN ZERO SB
FOURTEEN IS OUT.
ITEM TWO SB.
ONE FOUR EIGHT PATTERSON
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO HI. ELEVEN ZERO SB ONE
FORTY EIGHT IS OUT.
ITEM FOUR SB -- TWO NINE SIX
WHEN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
THE HONOR IN MY IN.
STILL EIGHT ZERO SB TWO NINETY
SIX IS OUT.
ITEM.
FIVE SB [inaudible]
THREE FIVE FOUR PATTERSON
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I NINE ONE SB THREE
FIVE FOUR IS OUT [inaudible]
ITEM.
EIGHT SB -- FOUR SIX SEVEN WHEN
[inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I TEN ZERO SB FOUR SIX
SEVEN IS OUT.
ITEM NINE SB -- FIVE EIGHT SIX
WHEN.
PATTERSON. TEN ZERO SB FIVE
EIGHT SIX IS OUT.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ELEVEN ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT THAT IT IS [inaudible]
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH. THREE MINUTES THIRTY EIGHT
SECONDS [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH
[inaudible]
BOB
OF THOSE
[inaudible]
ONE L. K.
AT NUMBER FOUR SB TWO NINE SIX
IRWIN -- WHEN I PATTERSON?
SO NINE ZERO SB. TWO NINETY SIX
IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT SB FOUR SIX SEVEN
IRWIN -- WHEN I PATTERSON
[inaudible] ELEVEN ZERO SB FOUR
SIX SEVEN IS OUT.
ITEM NINE SB -- FIVE EIGHT SIX
WHEN I WHEN I PATTERSON. ELEVEN
ZERO SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX IS OUT
[inaudible]
ROGER [inaudible]
THANK YOU